as many of you guys know apple's
spring-loaded event is happening
tomorrow
and last week i published a video early
morning on wednesday
claiming that the 24-inch apple silicon
imac is coming at the event
and today i'm even more convinced than i
was
last week so in this video i'm gonna go
more in-depth than i've ever gone before
in terms of predictions
for a new product laying out everything
from the design
the specs price internals and more but
first i want to mention that when i made
the claim that the imac is coming
most tech blogs and youtubers were
doubting that an imac would get released
until at least wwdc in june but i
doubled down
and said that i would shave my goatee if
i'm wrong which of course
isn't as big of a deal as john's
eyebrows
but lucky for me throughout the entire
week we got more and more convincing
rumors
pointing to an imac releasing tomorrow
so let's get into that before i get in
depth
with the new apple silicon imac after my
24 inch imac confirmed video was
uploaded and scheduled for the next
morning a mac rumors forum member shared
an image of the apple event invite logo
which he flipped over and as it turns
out it
almost perfectly matches the el
within the hello text that was shown in
an ad
for the original macintosh and that same
day mark german from bloomberg
who was a very reliable leaker mention
it during an
interview that the event won't feature
anything particularly innovative
except the imac if it does actually come
at the event now this is a
really really huge deal because prior to
this interview
mark actually claimed that the
redesigned imac
would not be coming until the third
quarter of this year
and that was actually the only thing
that was making me have
doubts about the imac coming at the
event but
now he totally changed his mind
so that's a relief and then after that
he posted
this on twitter basically asking if it
would be weird if the imac
came with the m1 chip pointing to a
release
long before the powerful m1x chip is
ready to launch
and then after that love to dream also a
very reliable leaker
hinted at the colors from the
spring-loaded event logo
matching the colors of the original
multi-colored imac
and if you didn't already know john
prosser had some renders created
based on leaked info that the new
redesigned imax would be getting new
colors
and left a dream basically agreed with
him on multiple occasions
especially this most recent one soon
after all of that many tech blogs and
youtubers and even leakers
started getting hyped up for a potential
imac release at the event
including luke miani greg's gadgets
sam from i update in appletrek.com
taylor of tech nikki s molina and
gio riku who is going on record and
offering up his eyebrows in case he's
wrong
and even max weinbach a fairly reliable
leaker as well
and his reasoning was that production
started late last year on this
imac and that perfectly matches up with
john pross's rumor from last month
mentioning that the new imac is ready
and could launch
at any time but the only weird thing is
that in john's latest video
he said he would lose his mind if the
imac gets released at the event tomorrow
so i wonder why he isn't as confident as
others
but beyond that on friday we got a
report that the amount of
in stock 21.5 inch imacs have been
dropping
as we're getting closer to this event
which is very common to see
before a new model comes out especially
since last month
they discontinued the higher storage
models
which usually never happens and just a
few days ago apple apparently advised
retailers
to prepare for new products with new
randomized
serial numbers in my theory is that
every new apple silicon imac with a
redesign is gonna have
one of these new serial numbers this
would help apple
rid the world of hackintosh systems that
tried to use a serial code
to make imessage and facetime work
properly
so sorry hackintoshes on top of that
webbush securities
mentioned that there could be a few
surprises at tomorrow's event
including new imacs with a range of
color options
so based on all of that the evidence for
an imac launch tomorrow is even more
clear
than it was when i made that video last
week
but if i'm wrong i will be shaving my
goatee
in the next video i make after this one
so subscribe
right now for a chance to see that if i
am wrong now with all of that said
let's get in depth with my predictions
for the new apple silicon imac
most rumors pointed to the imac either
having a 23
or 24 inch display and i personally
think it's gonna be a 24
inch since apple seems to be recently
switching over
to even numbers with the rumored 14
and 16 inch macbook pro models as well
as the recent
32 inch pro display xdr now as far as
the resolution
i think that apple is actually going to
go with 4.5 k
and here's why apple's current retina
imac displays have kind of weird
resolutions
because apple's goal for retina quality
is to hit around 218 or 220 pixels per
inch
as you can see with the 27 inch 5k imac
as well as the 32 inch
pro display xdr and of course the 21.5
inch
4k retina imac which actually has
a 4.1 k resolution a bit higher
just so we could hit that 218
ppi requirement but if you take that
same 4.1 k resolution
and change it to a 24 inch display it
goes all the way down to 196 ppi
which is not enough to be considered
retina
so i ended up finding the perfect
resolution that maintains
a perfect 16 by 10 aspect ratio
while keeping the ppi just slightly
higher
than the retina 218. so i think it's
going to be around
4480 by 2800 resolution
now there is a chance that it's gonna
have a 5k display
but it'll lead to an overkill amount of
ppi
for a 24 inch display so i'm sticking
with 4.5 k and i want to mention that it
probably is not gonna have mini led
or anything like that now as far as the
exterior design
i made a video way back in september
predicting what the imac redesign would
look like
and i basically said that it would look
similar to a pro display xdr
with the ipad pro like bezels and the
completely flat sides and
back except that it definitely will not
be getting
those cheese grater holes which will
then make the sides thinner
than the ones on the pro display xdr i
also mentioned that the stand will be
more square
shaped like the pro display stand
compared to the current imax
wedge shape design except that it
definitely
would not have an adjustable hinge the
one on the new imac will go into the
chassis
like the current stand already does and
then a couple of months back
john prosser showed off renders of the
new imac
and those are basically spot on with
what i expect
except that in his renders you can't
really see the vents
on the back since i do think there's
going to be a fan
and i'll get into that in just a second
now the only thing that i initially got
different compared to what john prosser
showed
off is that i expected the iconic imac
chin to stick around but get shrunk down
significantly compared to the current
massive chain and at this point i'm
really not sure about if we should be
expecting the chin or not
since most recent leaks and renders
point to no
chin at all but i guess we'll have to
see now as far as the internal layout
you can see the 2017
21.5 inch imac right here and as you can
see
there are huge speaker enclosures on the
sides a bulky hard drive
and a thick fan enclosure in the center
a power supply on the bottom
and the main logic board on the right
now here is where it gets
very interesting with the new apple
silicon imac
the large hard drive is going away
forever
since we know that the storage will be
soldered on to the logic board
the huge power supply on the bottom will
be significantly reduced in size
since apple silicon barely uses any
power compared to intel
chips and then looking at the main logic
board the huge heat sink will be greatly
reduced in size
and made much thinner the ram will now
be soldered
directly onto the logic board so it's
going to be much
thinner and there will most likely not
be discrete graphics on the 24 inch imac
so the overall size of the logic board
will be reduced as well
so with all of that we're talking a
massive reduction in the overall
footprint of the internals so apple can
flatten
everything down to fit in a thin flat
back chassis
that will likely be slightly larger than
the last one to accommodate
the larger 24 inch display and yes i do
think that there is going to be a fan
with vents on the back because as the
years go on
the chips will be getting more and more
powerful so they may as well just add
the fan in the vents
right now instead of having to do it
later as far as the ports you can expect
it to have basically the same ones
as the current 21 and a half inch imac
except
with usb 4 ports instead of thunderbolt
3. and as far as the price i have a
pretty good feeling that the starting
price will be around
thirteen hundred dollars since that's
the price of the current
retina 4k 21.5 inch model
and the new one will for sure have a
retina display at the base price
now apple could end up dropping the
price by maybe a hundred dollars
but i feel like since we're getting a
full imac redesign
people will gladly pay thirteen hundred
dollars for the 24 inch imac now as far
as the chip and the specs
i'm now 100 sure that the base model
will get the same m1 ship that we
already have
some people think apple could go the
expensive route and just give the base
model
the upcoming 12 core m1x chip but that
would make the starting price much
higher and i don't think apple would do
that because apple usually offers a
variety of colors
on their lower end products like the
iphone 12
and ipad air to target a younger aged
market
so if that's apple's goal with all of
these new colors
then they would need to keep the base
price down probably no higher than 1300
and in my opinion i do not think that
the larger imac coming later this year
is gonna have those colors i think
they're gonna keep it very simple
and i even think they're gonna call it
the imac pro
so do not expect colors on the larger
imacs
now you might think it's crazy for
someone to pay 1300
for an m1 imac when you can just get an
m1 mac mini
for 700 but keep in mind that you're
getting
a retina quality 24 inch display and
the magic mouse and magic keyboard
included with the imac
so it's actually still a pretty good
value especially with the new
design and i'll even go as far as to say
that there's a good chance
the mouse and the keyboard will match
the body color of the imac
since that's what they did with the imac
g3 now as far as the specs i expect
everything to be almost
identical to the m1 mac mini 256 gigs of
ssd storage
and 8 gigs of unified ram at the base
price
with most likely the same upgrade
options but the one thing i do expect to
get upgraded
is the webcam so it'll probably pack
1080p resolution
which many people have been asking for
so there you guys go
i think that's just about everything and
less than 24 hours from right now
will know exactly what i got wrong and
what i got right
if there even is an imec announcement in
the first place
but if there isn't and we have to wait
until later this year
you can almost certainly expect the new
imac
to at least have the m1x chip as an
upgrade option
no doubt about it so hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you did
click that circle above to subscribe
right now so you can
watch me shave my goatee just in case
that i'm wrong
and definitely check out one of those
two videos right there
and i'll see you tomorrow
you